[Musique]
technopole de sophia antipolis près de
cannes pour la première fois une caméra
est admise dans le saint des saints de
la cosmétique
xavier ormancey dirige ce laboratoire de
recherche pour chanel son équipe de
chimistes tu rates les molécules actives
dans des plantes venues du monde entier
il distille fractionne pulvérise les
végétaux pour en extraire le meilleur
est concentrée malgré dian qui est
totalement naturel est totalement pur
l'inquiéter sens mais le patron du
laboratoire se méfie de l'espionnage
industriel
les secrets de fabrication doivent
rester secrets alors d'un ce carton
galates dernière révolution des
nanotechnologies pony fractionnant donc
elle est ultra confidentielle elle
encore au stade expérimental
donc on veut pas la voir on peut pas
vous la montre et je suis désolé mais
peut-être dans quelques années on aura
sera ravi de vous la présenter mais pour
l'instant là aussi c'est top secret
l'enjeu commercial est énorme il s'agit
de formuler les crèmes antirides les
best seller de la marque vendus jusqu'à
230 euros le pot le chimiste doit
innover en permanence aller chercher les
nouvelles molécules jusqu'au bout du
monde
depuis dix ans xavier ormancey parcourt
le globe pour dénicher la plante
efficace contre le vieillissement de la
peau alors on va se servir de cette base
ici pour collecter différents
échantillons et cet arbre là est notre
source de tg donc fameuse molécule anti
âge on est venu chercher spécifiquement
dans cette forêt malgache madagascar une
île de l'océan indien à riche de
milliers de plantes uniques au monde
cette flore est encore mal connue et
xavier ormancey n'est pas le seul à
vouloir percer les secrets des forêts
malgaches sur place nous allons
rencontrer d'autres français passionnés
olivier berra fait l'inventaire de cette
richesse naturelle et barbara mathevon
se bat pour la préserver
comment trouve-t-il de nouvelles plantes
comment sont-elles tester
pourquoi ce patrimoine risque t'il de
partir en fumée
enquête à madagascar sur les pas des
sauveurs de plantes et des chercheurs de
senteurs
notre voyage commence au nord de
madagascar près de l'île touristique de
nocibé cette région est l'une des plus
pauvres du monde
on y cultive du café du cacao et des
fleurs dit languit langue utilisée par
les parfumeurs des plantations hérités
de la période coloniale
quand madagascar était encore une île
française nous y retrouvons xavier
ormancey le patron de la recherche de
chanel chaque mois le chimiste part aux
quatre coins du monde ces derniers
voyages le tibet l'australie l'indonésie
le brésil des pays avec une flore
exceptionnelles mais c'est à madagascar
qu'il trouve le plus de plantes
intéressantes
madagascar cette unité devant une très
grande vous avez donc différentes zones
agro climatiques différents climats et
donc les espèces botaniques la
biodiversité varie vraiment d'une zone à
l'autre dont vous avez accès comme ça on
quelque part en vous déplaçant de
quelques centaines de kilomètres là des
univers botanique qui sont très
différentes
ça vous plaît ça me plaît parce
qu'effectivement chaque fois on va
découvrir presque une autre un autre
univers
d'autres pratiques d'autres plantes et
ça ça ça va vendre inspiré première
étape le scientifique bien surveiller la
culture d'une vanille très particulière
à l'ombre d'un filet des centaines de
pieds sont bichonnés pour la marque de
luxe revanche aux gens c'est ton brière
est unique au monde
nous sommes au moment de la récolte on
voit effectivement que les ballets sont
combien vont fournir bien nourris on a
largement dix fruits par balle et un
minimum d'eau des frais qui sont en
fusion bonne sans terre ils sont bien
développées antérieurement c'est ne
s'intéresse ni au goût ni au parfum des
gousses de vanille il mise sur une
propriété caché de cette variété
malgache vanilla planifolia donc cette
manie particulière qu'on trouve ici en
banque dans l'engrais gascard qui a la
particularité de contenir des taux très
élevé de molécules actives anti âge et
c'est ce qu'on était venu chercher cette
espèce contient une forte concentration
en police et tonnes des molécules censé
lutter contre le vieillissement de la
peau au lieu de fabriquer ses molécules
en laboratoire le chimiste a préféré
trouver dans la nature
la planta plus riche en principes actifs
et il a déniché dans cette région
reculée de madagascar
alors mon rôle c'est un peu
effectivement chercher ce qu'on appelle
les trésors cachés la nature d'aller
puiser dans cette immense magasin a
passé un magasin du bon dieu d'aller
chercher tout un tas de plantes de
molécules et d'aller puiser dans cette
immense ressource végétale naturelle et
d'y trouver ma des molécules actives ce
trésor de la nature entre depuis deux
ans dans la composition de la crème
antirides star de la marque
un pari osé car cette vanille les
cultiver nulle part ailleurs toute la
chaîne de fabrication dépend de la
petite récolte de cette exploitation
c'est dur et paris avec du vivant
il ya un risque associé à la culture du
vivant c'est vrai et en même temps c'est
la magie du vivant c'est le côté naturel
des choses est pour l'instant en vain
coup d'envoi toucher du bois ou toucher
de lanus on n'a pas encore une de ces
colis ci qui a endommagé notre notre
mourir mais le chimiste n'est pas venu
de france uniquement pour cette venir il
est sur une piste encore plus
prometteuse
à l'autre bout du pays direction les
forêts tropicales de l'est de l'île à
800 km de là à partir de nocibé il faut
une heure d'avion pour rejoindre la
capitale tananarive
puis quatre heures de route et plus
d'une heure de marche avant d'arriver
dans la réserve de vaud imana
ici il reste encore de nombreuses
plantes tropicales à découvrir xavier
ormancey retrouve un autre français
passionné par cette nature olivier berra
vit à madagascar depuis 20 ans
c'est le meilleur connaisseur de cette
forêt humide j'essaie d'être un peu de
grenouilles joly qui ressemble à une
feuille le français a recensé autant
d'espèces de grenouilles dans cette
forêt qu'il y en a dans toute l'europe
depuis cinq ans il gère cette réserve
avec son ong l'homme et l'environnement
il veut préserver un écosystème unique
on a dix mille plantes endémiques à
madagascar sur treize mille plantes y en
a dix mille qu'on trouve qu'à madagascar
est tous assez concentré à 80% sur la
côte est justement cette forêt de
moyenne altitude dans laquelle on est
olivier berra a inventorié plus de 130
plantes les fleurs les feuilles ou les
fruits de ces plantes contiennent des
principes actifs qui peuvent intéresser
les industriels
pour voir tous là toute la magie de la
forêt tu as ta ce petit fruit aussi qui
vient de cette plante qui se mange ta
soupe petits fruits aussi qui se mange
ça aussi c'est ce mot ses fruits ne sont
pas seulement comestibles les malgaches
se servent de certaines de ces plantes
pour rester en bonne santé
au bord du chemin un fruits colorés
attire l'oeil du scientifique mais bon
la toile couleurs superbes
qu'est ce que c'est isabelle et n'a donc
ce sont les fruits de cette plante qui
est consommée est traditionnellement
pour apporter l'énergie c'est une sorte
de dire de kiwi d'orange local pour les
populations sont riches en vitamines
sels minéraux molécules énergisante donc
ça c'est un produit qui intéresse
beaucoup parce que c'est un fruit
donc on peut le prélever sans d'être la
plante et on pourrait regarder comment
ces molécules énergisantes ces vitamines
pour être transposée utilisées pour des
applications sur la peau pour l'étude
roger petit et évité et que donc plus
comme nous l'équipe récolte quelques
fruits de cette isabey l'ena pour les
analyser en france il y a deux ans
xavier ormancey à repérer dans cette
forêt un arbre avec un formidable
potentiel cosmétiques il a demandé à
olivier berra de lancer une plantation
expérimentale
c'est en à 2000 comme ça d'ailleurs et
2020 ces zones on sait les arbres qu'il
faut quoi cinq mètres c'est ça on
entasse ainsi mais toujours faire
s'inquiète dire la dent 6 moteurs il
faut un mètre cinquante
cet arbre un parfum de secret le
chercheur lui a donné un nom de code le
maroni nous avons le droit de le filmer
mais interdiction de donner son nom
véritable le laboratoire veut garder une
longueur d'avancé sur ses concurrents
on va trouver madagascar on est très
content d'avoir trouvé c'était ce
n'était pas forcément évident même si ça
paraît simple de trouver place autour de
nous il n'ya pas tendre piste qui
aboutissent et c'était logique aussi de
la cultiver là où elle était présente et
d'autres chercheurs n'ont pas cette
éthique
il y a quelques années un laboratoire
pharmaceutique américain est venu pillé
une plante malgache
on a eu un exemple assez rigolo avec la
pervenche de madagascar qui est une
plante qui sert à faire un médicament
pour la leucémie infantile et qui traite
80 % des leucémies infantiles maintenant
son centre était géré grâce à cette
paire l'ange de madagascar est une
industrie là peu scrupuleuses je dire
américaine ils ont pris des plans ils
sont dit tiens on va faire des
plantations au texas vers laisse tomber
des petits malgaches qui collecte les
plans et ça a été extraordinaire pascal
américaine ils ont fait des surfaces
énorme et en fait ça a poussé très bien
et beaucoup d'engrais chimiques et en
fait ils sont trouvés avec zéro principe
actif dans la plante donc c'était assez
super donc toi c'est la nature la kia
qui a fait la protection de son terroir
et qui a dit c'est ici que je produis
bien ce qu'il faut agir autrement allez
vous faire voir que les produits
chimiques pour pousser vite la fois ça
se développe bien t on exactement dans
les temps quelques mois voilà une autre
plante médicinale à côté c'est
naturellement l'eau ong voient les
choses en grand
elle veut planter 7000 pieds de marrons
guy dans l'année cette culture permet
aussi de reboiser ces zones défrichées
donc tout ce qu'on essaye de faire ici
vraiment c'est trouver comment on peut
valoriser ce patrimoine malgache veut
dire pour les malgaches avant tout dire
si ça sert à faire des produits
cosmétiques chèques qui seront du très
cher quand même je crois
grand bien leur fasse je veux dire c'est
pas répondu non nous on s'en fout nous
ce qui nous importe c'est cette
valorisation des plantes malgache qui
peut motiver les populations locales à
préserver leur environnement et arrêter
tout le feu partout
car c'est le drame de la forêt malgache
elle part en fumée au rythme effrayant
de 250 mille hectares par an d'ici 15
ans tout pourrait disparaître à vos
imana avant l'arrivée de lohan chez les
habitants brûlaient la forêt pour faire
pousser du riz
ces arbres calcinés témoigne de ce mode
traditionnel de culture sur brûlis
le problème est que le sol s'appauvrit
très vite la terre a mis à nu les berges
des rivières s'effondre
[Musique]
après une heure de marche
olivier berra emmène l'équipe de
scientifiques dans un autre champ qu'au
coin peut ici il y à de grands maroobe
la plante secret ces propriétés sont
elles vraiment efficace contre le
vieillissement de la peau de ce type là
toi dès que tu couple à cette plante est
utilisée pour la cicatrisation donc
cicatrisation renouvellement cellulaire
donc renouvellement cellulaire voilà on
va aider la peau à retrouvé son
dynamisme à se régénérer à se renouveler
et donc on est typiquement dans le
traitement des pauvres qui sont matures
qui sont âgés qui perdent un petit peu
de ses propriétés la raison qu'on pense
que ces molécules à venir supplée la
peau et l'aider à à corriger les signes
de l'âge ces précieuses molécules se
trouveraient dans la sève orange de la
plante
c'est ce que xavier ormancey et son
équipe devront analyser dans leurs
laboratoires en france
[Musique]
dp efira commun d'ici la famille ils
reviendront l'an prochain pour suivre la
culture du maroni il compte aussi sur le
responsable de l'oim ng pour leur
dénicher d'autres trésors de cette forêt
[Musique]
olivier bérard est devenu un spécialiste
reconnu des plantes de madagascar et de
leurs vertus
le plus étonnant il n'est ni botaniste
ni agronome il s'est d'abord fait un nom
en étudiant des reptiles je suis un
passionné crocodile et qui est devenu en
simplement par passion des plus grands
spécialistes de crocodile au monde on
pourrait le dire mais en démarrant tout
petit je veux dire comme soigneur
d'animaux au zoo de vincennes après j'ai
pu rentrer au muséum national d'histoire
naturelle et je suis devenu a reconnu de
par le monde nombre parce que j'étais un
grand scientifique simplement parce que
j'ai été dans les endroits où personne
n'avait jamais été à les oliviers berra
a passé plusieurs années sur les fleuves
africains à côtoyer les crocodiles il
découvre madagascar en venant observé
l'unique espèce qui vit dans des grottes
c'est sympa de travail sur les
crocodiles mais quand on a 20 ans lire
après c'est un peu plus sympa de
travailler sur des essences aromatiques
que sur les crocodiles quand on a un
passé quelques années dans les marécages
à vos imana il ne se contente pas de
recenser les plantes aromatiques
il aide aussi les villageois à vivre de
la forêt berra a lancé la production de
nouvelles huiles essentielles comme
celle du gingembre papillon une variété
endémiques de l'île il a fait venir un
alambic au coeur de la forêt l'intérêt
c'est un big c'est que les gens ils
peuvent collecter leurs plantes et les
transformer ici sur place donc et gagner
une plus value dont qu'ils ont un
produit qui peuvent sortir grâce à 7,1
me autrement ce serait pas possible de
dire de ramener déploya tadanari pour
les destiner s'assèche ici faut que les
plantes soit fraîche donc l'alambic leur
permet de distiller directement les
feuilles sur place est de produire
quelque chose avec leurs ressources
ainsi les villageois préfère récolter
ses feuilles plutôt que de brûler la
forêt pour faire des cultures de riz
cette huile essentielle de gingembre
papillon et certifiés bio elle est déjà
commercialisée en france avec succès
elle aurait un effet tonifiant sur
l'organisme
c'est un produit rare il faut énormément
de feuilles pour en produire très peu
treize millilitres avec 190 kg de
feuilles mais produit magique et pour
vendre ce produit magique
olivier berra joue même les vrp
[Musique]
paris quelques semaines plus tard nous
retrouvons le naturaliste dans un décor
où il ne passe pas inaperçu
il vient de faire dix mille kilomètres
pour faire découvrir une nouvelle huile
essentielle à l'un de ses distributeurs
français de se fermer un kilo quand il
m'a dit eh bien en belgique
[Musique]
c'est du solide
si on arrive à commercialiser cette
huile ça nous permet d'installer un
nouvel alambic qui permettra de nouveau
à 50,60 femme veut dire de travail et la
production d'une nouvelle lui donc
d'avoir une nouvelle alternative à la
fin de la réunion olivier berra a une
petite urgence il a un biberon à donner
c'est un petit rares ou de la forêt
c'est d'espèces endémiques de madagascar
si je l'avais abandonné ministre est bon
parce qu'il a perdu sa maman et
du tout ce vraiment le choix ce petit
rat a fait le voyage depuis madagascar
soigneusement cachée dans cette boîte
pour mon prochain but long mais l'étape
la plus importante de son voyage en
france se déroule au laboratoire de
recherche à nesle le directeur du
laboratoire xavier ormancey attend avec
impatience les premiers extraits réalisé
à partir du mahroum lit la plante
secrète qui l'a sélectionné à madagascar
tu prennes la différence différents mois
les chercheurs vont percer la
composition chimique de la plante et
comparer l'action de ces molécules à
celle de plantes déjà utilisé en
cosmétique comme le thé vert thé vert a
qui vont en marche mais mon bonhomme
banon
et puis on revient quand même que les
données de marrons gris sont beaucoup
plus performant il faut beaucoup plus
prononcée mais on voit qu elle il
vaudrait peut-être mieux diriger la
l'extrait numéro un qui est plus riche
sur ce texte n'allait sûrement en tant
qu'antioxydants que l'extrait vide le
numéro 2 l'extrait numéro 2 contenait
des feuilles et des branches de marhoum
guy le premier extrait uniquement des
feuilles un petit détail mais qui peut
avoir un impact sur le terrain voilà
donc la feuille est plus intéressante
que ce n'est plus branche c'est
intéressant on a comme en matière facile
pratique pour vous oui
loin c'est tout ça veut dire sur de
paiements chaque fois il faut quand même
une régénération des branches alors
questionné sur les feuilles assez encore
tous en retour elles seules poussons les
élèves elle repousse secondes
les premiers résultats sur le maroni
sont encourageants il possède des
propriétés anti oxydants olivier veyrat
lui compte beaucoup sur la culture de
cet arbre pour apporter des revenus aux
malgaches mais rien n'est gagné sur
semblant étudier dans ce laboratoire
seuls deux ou trois finir on réellement
dans une crème de beauté les plantes de
madagascar connaissent déjà un grand
succès sous forme d'huiles essentielles
elles sont réputées biologiques et
naturels en quelques années elles sont
devenues les vedettes des magasins bio
plus étonnant ces plantes sont de plus
en plus utilisé pour soigner les
sportifs de haut niveau
adrianna lamalle et double championne de
france 200 m e
c'est un espoir de médaille olympique
elle est en pleine préparation avant les
jeux de pékin
pour ces massages son kiné utilise
quelques gouttes d'huile essentielle de
madagascar le corps est comme une
machine qu'il faut entretenir qu'il faut
il faut cajoler faut il faut maintenir
en bonne forme et je pense que ça passe
par des massages ça passe aussi par port
l'utilisation des meilleurs produits la
championne d'athlétisme se sert des
huiles essentielles pour se booster
avant une compétition où se relaxer
après l'effort mais ce n'est pas un
produit miracle sont là pour soigner
aussi à les huiles ne font pas tout mais
au moins c'est un adjuvant qui me semble
vraiment très très utile très efficace
par rapport à une crème en mettrait
absolument rien ça c'est sûr c'est
indéniable elles sont déjà dans sa lutte
les plantes de madagascar aideront tels
les sportifs français à gagner des
médailles aux prochains jeux olympiques
un homme en est persuadé que laurent
berline et le pdg d'un laboratoire
spécialisé dans les huiles essentielles
il a rendez vous au comité olympique
français nous sommes à quelques semaines
de l'ouverture des jeux de pékin
il vient présenter un cocktail sur
mesure au kinésithérapeute qui vont
soigner les athlètes français le faire
parce que carrément le flacon pour y
mettre quelques gouttes au creux de la
main
et puis vous allez voir fait une
innovation comme ceux ci ça dégage à
fond les huiles essentielles sélectionné
pour les jo c'est une première
chaque athlète va partir à pékin avec sa
petite fiole aux senteurs malgache
le but du cocktail lutter contre les
effets de la pollution
vous avez besoin l'essentiel de
madagascar bien sûr le sarrau ainsi que
le niaouli qui pousse dans l'est de
madagascar et là on a quelque chose qui
est au niveau respiratoire est
magnifique
le niaouli des sportifs arrivent du goût
du monde de ce petit village de pêcheurs
de la côte est de madagascar au bord du
canal des pangalanes nous y rencontrons
barbara mathevon cette jeune française
s'est installé ici il ya cinq ans après
des études de biologie et
d'environnement l'huile essentielle de
niaouli c'est grâce à elle elle a su
exploiter le potentiel de ce petit
d'eucalyptus classe et pourtant comme
une peste végétale
c'est une plante qui a été importées par
les colons à l'époque du creusement du
canal des pangalanes et pour maintenir
les berges donc de du canada de scan a
nouvellement creuser ils ont dispersé
par avion des graines de niaouli et donc
ça ça tellement bien pris que c'est
devenu ultra en la hissant et sur le
canal maintenant on trouve
principalement que ce à quoi cet arbre
considéré comme une mauvaise herbe par
les malgaches est aujourd'hui une source
de revenus chaque jour des villageois
viennent récolter des centaines de kilos
de feuilles de niaouli on peut produire
2800 tonnes d'huiles essentielles par an
avec la ressource dont on dispose et
puis comme on a à partir du moment où on
coupe on booste aussi la plante au
niveau de ses feuilles
on n'a aucun problème de durabilité
d'exploitation ou peut maintenir ce
potentiel à pour les populations locales
à l'anneau car cette cueillette est une
petite révolution pour les villageois
razafy et mère de sept enfants
elle a maintenant un revenu stable
avant je pêche à des poissons dans le
canal mais le problème c'est qu'en hiver
je n'en trouvais pas assez pour nourrir
ma famille connecter des feuilles me
permet de gagner plus facilement de
l'argent en une journée de travail
chaque collector rapporte en moyenne 100
kg de feuilles au village lohan chez
l'homme et l'environnement a mis en
place une coopérative
le salaire est d'un euro 40 par jour
quarante pour cent de plus que le smic
malgache l'exploitation du niaouli a
sauvé ce village de pêcheurs de la
misère une institutrice supplémentaire a
été engagée grâce au bénéfice de la
coopérative
ce qui me rend fier c'est quand les gens
s'approprient vraiment des activités
qu'on a qu'on a mis en place donc quand
les gens sont contents de faire leur
travail en fait les pépiniéristes vont
en forêt qui sont contents parce qu'il
me dise tiens on a trouvé enfin la
graine de telles espèces donc on va
pouvoir le mettre en pépinière là je
sais que ça y est quoi c ils ont compris
l'utilité des trucs et ils prennent
plaisir à leur travail c'est vraiment ça
qu'on cherche
barbara mathevon a aussi aidé les
villageois à ouvrir un petit magasin
pour vendre 18 l'essentiel aux touristes
de passage le niaouli et le plus
apprécié son parfum est extraordinaire
vous promenez vous le sentez partout
c'est fantastique
aux etats unis comme en europe les
huiles essentielles sont à la mode
je mets des huiles essentielles sur ma
peau sur les oreillers dans le bain oui
beaucoup dans le bain et vous en pensez
quoi
je trouve ça très bien ça sent très bon
je pensais que c'était juste pour se
parfumer je ne connaissais pas les
utilisations thérapeutiques 1
avant de quitter madagascar barbara
mathevon tient à nous faire découvrir un
joyau la réserve de vos ebooks pour y
parvenir nous partons en pirogue sur des
trois canaux au milieu de plantes
géantes
cette jeune française s'est battue pour
sauver une forêt menacée
[Musique]
donc là on arrive sur le lac dans good
in at donc c'est un grand lac qui nous
à peu près jusqu'à la moitié de vous et
brûlant sa longueur 7 fort a été
condamné à disparaître sous les coups de
hache des bûcherons qui exploitait le
bois exotique une espèce de forêt
témoins de ce qui existait auparavant à
l'époque où du nord au sud on avait une
forêt littorale lo ng a obtenu du
ministère de l'environnement et des
forêts d'interdire l'accès de cette
réserve aux trafiquants de bois si
barbara mathevon nous emmène ici c'est
pour nous montrer sa dernière découverte
vous voyez là le tronc à mener c'est un
panier qui a été découvert l'année
dernière avec nos partenaires américains
qui sont des spécialistes dans les
paniers
donc on est en train de décrire pour lui
donner un nom s'appellera probablement
nom d'espèce louis boulet nice voilà
donc le pnue et bull est un peu plus
loin
la jeune française nous dévoile un
dernier survivant de la forêt primaire
pour cet instinct schizo l'ena lorina
c'est une de nos quatre espaces ultra
menace est donc classée 8 scènes
menacées d'extinction immédiate parce qu
il en reste moins de 30 individus et il
n'en reste plus que dans la forêt de
louis bulle
les premiers tests faits sur les
feuilles de ces arbres rescapés prouve
qu'il regorge de principes actifs pour
l'instant pas question d'y toucher
barbara mag on a maintenant l'espoir de
sauver cette espèce en pépinière